Hello listener. My name is Jason. I will be one of three hosts. I'm a non-time host. You're going to have a couple of tardy hosts joining us soon. If not, you're just going to get me. Just a solo episode with me. I hope that's not your future. But until then, let me tell you a little bit about myself. I'm a Capricorn, a Sage Moon. I love things sweetened with anything other than sugar. I've had addiction issues. I've got a handle on that. I think unless you put something sweetened with sugar in front of me, it's a real trigger situation for me. I just go right down a hillside full of sin. Oh, just in time. Here are the idiots. Guys, welcome to Smart List.
The listener does not know this, but this is our second episode today that we're recording. So what did you guys do in between shows? I had a little egg sandwich that I made myself, not an egg salad sandwich like Sean would have made. You had an egg sandwich. Now, what was the bread? Was it actual bread? Not really. It was gluten-free bread that I had to toast to within an inch of its life. So it tasted decent. And then I put a little fake butter on it and then the eggs on top of it. I'm pretty sure the eggs were real. We had a conversation with our friend on a different episode about enjoying ourselves and stuff. But it tastes great. I enjoy it. Now, last night we went out for a family dinner to this
yummy little restaurant down the street that specializes in Italian food. So I ordered a nice big fat cheese pizza and I whipped down more of that than probably I should have. And we had some pasta and I had... In BH or in the valley? Down in Laurel Canyon. Oh, a little patch. Yeah. Yeah. A little patch. Oh, you went, you went, not patch. No, I know. But I say, patch, you leave it off. That's how you know that you're legit. Well, you leave it off. Hey, there's Maeve and she can't hear us. Oh, wait, wait, that was... Hi, Maeve. That was Maeve. Oh, yeah. She's over here. Are you guys going for dinner tonight together? We're going to go and we're going to go over to our friend's
house and we're going to celebrate our friend Sean because he's... He had a birthday a while ago. Yeah. He had a birthday a while ago. And ends... I wish I could be there with you. I know. I know. I'm going to miss you. Well, you know, we'll FaceTime. You FaceTimed in last week. I'll FaceTime. I will FaceTime again. Yeah, FaceTime in again. I will. I will. This face? You got to give it time. Who's got time for that? Does the rest of your body... Is the rest of your body as dark as your face, Will? Yeah, yeah, of course. No, I didn't ask to see it. Put your top back on. I know. That is a tan like nobody's ever seen. It's really good. So, do you read though... You said you read three books while you were there.
Was it just for the bounce effect of the paper? Or do you enjoy reading? He just opens it. That's the sun takeover. What were the three books? Do you remember them? Were they all nonfiction? Were they all World War II books? The Giving Tree. No. Again. I haven't finished my third, to be honest. What were the first two? Were they just... Were they just airport fiction? Well, one of them is my dad's book, Bean Fate, which I finally read, which is amazing. I'm so proud of my dad, Jim Arnett, who wrote a book during the pandemic, and he wrote this sort of fictionalized, this novel based on history. Got it published. Got it published. That's cool. Yeah, it's really cool. And honestly, I was reading it. I was
just thinking the whole time. I'm like, I'm so... My dad did this. I'm so proud of my dad. Yeah. So it's called Bean Fate, and it's really, really good. This is about the Bean Farmers of Calamongas. No, no, no. I think it's not the... It's a remake of the Bean War or something, right? Calamongas. The Milagro Bean Filled War. Yeah, good for him. Because I don't think they really got it on the last one. So, okay. No, it's about booze runners back, you know, prohibition style, you know, back in the day. Up in Saskatchewan, in the Bronfman family, et cetera. So I did that, and then I read The Sympathizer. Have you guys read that? No. What is that? I feel like I wrote it. It's written by Vietnamese American
author, Viet Thanh Nguyen. It's about the Vietnam War. And it's about the Vietnam War. And he himself is a Vietnamese origin. Descent. Descent and origin. And he came here when he was young. And so it just talks about the experience of... God, honestly, I couldn't have loved it more. But it's not just about that. It's just about such an unbelievable story of, I don't know, just that guy who led a complex life. And there were so many... Are there colored pictures in it? For me? Any pictures of him sympathizing with folks? So many incredible, incredible passages in the book that just blew me away that I would have to read out loud. I'll check that out. Yeah, I'll bet you $1,000 that you don't.
You won. Now, how do you decide what you're going to read when you're on the beach there? Like reading in the sun makes you want to... What I do is, sorry, then I just started... I'm now reading this Splendid in the Vile, which a lot of people have read. These are big books. The sympathizers are one that put surprise. Reading in the sun, to me, it's like being trapped in a hot car with the windows rolled up, stuck, broken. I don't know when the driver's coming back. Kind of have a three-year-old screaming in my ear. That's what reading on a hot beach sounds like to me. Really? Yeah, because I'm already sweating and I'm still...
And I have to concentrate on words? Yeah, and I got the hard balance off the paper. No, I can't do it. And I got sunglasses on and other sweats dripping on the glasses. I got to keep wiping the glasses. And I hear all the people having fun in the water. Yeah, it's I can't. You know what, though? I'm snacky. I get real hungry on the beach. You know what's amazing is our guest today. Great segue. Our guest today is so fun. I love her. She's like a big megastar. I'm no big deal. Wait, I've got it. It's a woman. I've got it. I've got it.
She's been on one of the hottest primetime dramas in the last few decades. She's born and raised in the Bronx. She's a New Yorker through and through. This might give it away. At a young age, she performed with the award-winning Tadda Youth Theater Teen Group. She graduated college with a double major in anthropology and sociology. Not the right one. Before winning an Emmy, one of her earliest acting kids was, I got to ask her about this, a traveling sex education sketch group. Her last name is not only a U.S. state, but also an Apple. Please welcome the beautiful and extremely talented, Carrie Washington. Carrie! Hello, Carrie!
Let's get right into it. A traveling, what is it? A sex education sketch group. It was not sketchy, although we did sketches. We were, oh my God, that's where we're starting. Okay. I'm so nervous. We are not journalists. I'm such a mega fan of the show, so I'm really excited and a little nervous. No, Michael. Listen, we're just hanging out. Yeah, you can already hear what idiots we are. Well, every episode, but that's why we love you.
Bring us up. When I was a high schooler, when I was a teenager, I worked for the Adolescent Health Center in New York City at Mount Sinai Hospital, and it was like the beginning of the AIDS epidemic, like late 80s, early 90s, and we used to, we wrote these sketches, these skits about safer sex issues and losing your virginity and drug abuse and LGBTQ rights. So it was like, I find you attractive. I find you attractive. Hold on, let me get a condom. What was like, how do you ask your boyfriend to put a condom on? Or how do you put a condom on? Or how do you make that conversation sexy? Because all the research was like, people
have the information, but the behavior change is not there. So we used to write these shows. I'd love to hear the first few wishes. I would too. By the way, I've had, God, Carrie, it's like you gave me a bat and you put me at the plate and I've just been standing here and you've just been throwing softballs at me. I'm doing all of my best because I want to impress you. Don't hold back.
Don't hold back. No, because I don't want to be just a total dirtbag and I'm just like, man. Be yourself. Well, be yourself. It's hard. It's hard. I'm a guest in your house. Do yourself. What was the draft that made it to the stage on how to put on a condom in a funny, funny
way? Well, we used to teach kids how to put condoms on by using bananas, so that always got to laugh. But it was really more like, I mean, the first sketch I was allowed to do was actually a scene about whether or not I was 13 when I started doing the show. So the only sketch they would let me do in the beginning was should I lose my virginity or not? And it was a whole sketch about my really cute boyfriend who's kind of pressuring me
and I don't know if I should or shouldn't. And then the cool part, and this was actually incredible acting training, was that the problems of the show were unresolved and we would stay in character after the show and the audience would solve our problems. We would ask the audience for advice. So they would be in conversation. I love to stay in character. Yeah, we stayed in character.
Then doesn't that mean the show is still going? No, the show would end and then we'd do a Q&A, but our Q&A would be in character. And sometimes I would be playing more than one character, so I'd have a baseball hat for the girl who wasn't sure she should lose her virginity and then a red scarf for the girl who was needed to tell her brother stop selling drugs. So we had all these different conflict issues and I got to develop character backstory and learn to be spontaneous and I found my yes and while doing sex education. What was this group that sounds somewhat charitable and altruistic?
You're judging me. I hear you judging me. No, but it sounds like you're doing great thing. I wish I was doing stuff at 13 that was going around and doing a lot of stuff. What do we show us for like hospitals, didn't you say this was like? Yeah, we performed at like schools and community centers. How did you get involved in that? That sounds like you were walking around with a bunch of very nice people.
I have a great parents. I was really into acting and my mom had read that there were auditions for this. I had done children's theater with that company that was mentioned, which is a company in midtown. And this was like for teenagers and my mom had seen an ad about it and my mother's an educator. So she was like, educational theater is a great thing. And then I came home with all these pamphlets about like gonorrhea and she was like, what
is this? But I'd love to see the one act on gonorrhea. Don't worry about it. We're going to put a condom over a banana. It'll be all good. We're going to fix the world's problems. One banana at a time. Funny thing happened on the way to the theater.
Exactly. Wait, Carrie, let's I want to get this out of the, okay, guys, I have kind of a long story. I was wondering if we were going to tell the story. We're going to do it. We're going to do it. We're just going to get past it because how could we not do it? Should Will and I lay down?
I was shocked that you asked me to be your guest because I was like, there's no way we're not telling this story. Of course we're talking about it. Me being punked by Sean Hayes. So these guys have no idea what I'm going to say. So it's like, if you can hang in there for like two minutes, which is a long time, but it's a long story because here we go. It's one of the most embarrassing things that's ever happened to me.
I was shooting a pilot last year and it's a long, long email to Carrie asking her to help me out and let me jump in. Let me jump in. It's the nicest email I've ever gotten in my life. It's a great email. You know the notes you get from a fan where you're like, I should maybe call security because this person is like, really loves me. It was that, but it was like from another famous person.
So it was okay. And it was like somebody that I respect and admire. So I was like, oh my God. I was so moved. I was deeply moved. Likewise. I meant every word. And then there was the ask at the bottom of it.
Always, always. So, but she, Carrie emailed me back, asked for my number, said, I'd love to call you to chat more about it. Great. Fantastic. Wonderful response. At the same time, I was guest hosting a few episodes of Jimmy Kimmel show. And while there had befriended a producer named Aaron, Aaron Irwin, who's now a friend.
So one night I went home from the shows. I got a text from on my phone saying, I'm watching you on Kimmel right now and you're doing great. And I was pleased by the message, but I was like perplexed because I didn't recognize the number. And then I decided, and I deduced that it was Aaron from Kimmel who was maybe watching like a rough cut of the show because we just exchanged phone numbers as I left the studio, but I hadn't put her contact info on my phone.
Here we go. So I pulled over and saved the number in my contacts as Aaron from Kimmel. Now I'm at home, cut to, I'm at home eagerly awaiting the call from Sean because this is my number one fan. I mean, my dad doesn't love me this much. And now I think I'm going to, I'm going to get a healing because somebody who loves me is going to get on the phone with me and it's going to change my life. And even though I'm going to say no to the ask, we're going to be friends forever.
Right. Right. Perfect. Right. Big load of junk food just to prop you up. Perfect. All right. So the phone rings.
I pick it up and say, Hey, and I see it's Aaron from Kimmel. What's going on? Aaron says, Hi, how are you? Your email is so sweet. I couldn't wait to talk to you. And I said, email. What email? And Aaron says, the email I sent you and I was like, I don't remember sending you an
email. Are you sure? And Aaron's phone shifted between us and I, and I said, Aaron said, is this Sean? And I said, yeah, who's this? And Aaron says, you didn't send me an email with your number. And then I turned it to a total asshole and I go, I think you have the wrong number. Why don't you check that email and your contact, then why don't you get back to me? And that's when Aaron was like, that's probably a good idea.
So I go sit down, I hang up the phone and I turn to my husband and I'm like, I'm being fucking punked because Sean Hayes sent me the nicest email I've ever gotten in my life. I just got off the phone with him and he was such a jerk to me and he's acting like I made up the email. I was like shaking. I was so, I was like, why would somebody do that? Does he think I'm untalented? I was so upset.
I go sit down and talk to my husband and I'm chatting. I'm telling you, I just got the craziest phone call and at 15 minutes in the conversation with Scotty, I did all the math and like a, like a shot in a movie came zooming towards my face. I go, I jumped up and I screamed, holy shit, that was Carrie Washington. And credits. Yeah. Open credits.
Yes. I texted you back immediately, explained everything and asked, begged for you to call me back and I answered the phone and you were laughing. I was, I couldn't stop laughing because I was really like, I thought I was being pranked and I was so relieved. It was so, so lovely. Wow. God, that was funny.
Yeah. My feelings were so hurt. And I was like, I'm being gaslit. Like he's gaslighting me. You guys have this great, now this great, like shared history. Beautiful. Are you jelly? You're jealous.
A little bit jelly. Because we only, we had our dinner. We sat next to each other. We didn't know each other. And we sat next to each other. You were there. Don't say whoa. You were there.
Yeah. You were across the table. Yeah. But I mean, when you guys worked for me, you know, you guys have all worked for me as a producer. We worked for you when we did the facts of life. Live in front of a studio audience. Wait.
Who was at this dinner? What are you talking about? Jason and Will were at it too. You know how we, when we did it, we had a cast dinner to kick off for our episode, which I wasn't a producer then. So I have. Oh, that's right. You were a producer on the set.
That's right. But I produced them the next two. And so these two. Oh, sorry. Tell the listener what we're talking about. Oh, we're talking about your sister. For your sister. This makes me so happy.
I'm in the family. We, for Norman Lear's live in front of a studio audience, which all three of you have graced us and blessed us with your performances and those specials. And if it weren't for really active producers like you and Justin Thoreau, that show would not be moving at all. I do a lot more than Justin Thoreau. Let me tell you something. Let me tell you something.
I just want to put that out there. Justin Thoreau, and he must be nominated for free, you know, producer's Guild Award this year. Because I mean, this guy. And that means. He rolls up his sleeves and he had them. He would have. He would have rolled them.
If he had had any sleeves, he would roll them up for sure. What is it with your thing with people not having sleeves? No, just Justin. It's just Justin. Everybody wears them except him. Yeah. Every day of his life, he has it cut off. Sometimes people wear them.
Don't have them with the gym and stuff. But not everybody just doesn't wear them ever. Even basketball players now wear sort of like a under sort of long sleeve thing. Yes. Yes. With a cuff. You know what usually deters people from going sleeveless? Winter.
It usually gets people to pop into a sleeve or two. Not him. Not this guy. Mosquito infestations. It doesn't matter to him. He's fearless that way. He's fearless that way. Will be right back.
And now back to the show. Kara, one thing I didn't know about you was, by the way, what a story we will have for the rest of our lives. The rest of our lives. That double major, anthropology and sociology, A, why, if you knew at such a young age you wanted to act, and do you have you utilized those, that degree? This is a great question. So it's actually a little more complicated into that, but that's the easy answer that
I give people. I designed an interdisciplinary major called performance studies. And it was inspired by, it was based on the graduate programs at NYU and Northwestern. So it was like the study that performance plays in different societies and cultures. And that's what interested me. But you have to, to design your own major, you have to write this whole thesis and defend it because they want to just make sure you're not trying to get out of taking statistics. So I had to kind of really work with all these academic mentors and come up with this program
and design a curriculum for myself. And yeah, I'm just, I'm super interested in how we perform like professionally, all of us, but also how we perform just in our everyday lives. And yeah, I think I have used a lot of it. I mean, I think, you know, what we, for me, I tend to think about characters in the kind of social science context, like when I'm playing a character, I like to think about how she's become who she is and how she thinks and how she lives in the world and how society impacts who she is.
So I do feel like I use some of my, I feel like such a nerd, I've been talking too long about this. I do. I use some of my social science. I was about to talk about my character room that I have here and I go into my character room and I've kept all the costumes of my great characters, all my costumes. Yes, yes, through the years. Now, Kerry, I'm the dumbest of the four of us.
Will you define anthropology for me? Pause, pause. He is. Yeah. Go ahead. Anthropology is the study of society, yes? Sociology is more the study of society. There go the name.
Anthropology. Yes. Anthropology is. Anthropology is more about ants. Is this, is this just about ants and the ant culture, right? I mean, no. It's more, it's more, anthropology is more indigenous cultures and historical culture. So not present day society, but more the role of kind of how societies have evolved through
times. Sociology would be the modern day version of anthropology. Yes. More modern day. That's enough will. That's enough will. Anthropology has a little more ritual, like study of ritual. Yeah.
But it's also a fabulous story. See, there's my fellow dumb dumb right there. Hi. I like anthropology. I like their stuff. Well, you'd like the sympathizer. It's a great book. Oh, hey.
Actually, I'm kidding. So when did you go, it did. Did you go to NYU? Is that what you were saying? No, no, no. I look, they, those NYU in Northwestern were the schools that had graduate degrees in performance studies that I admired and was interested in, but I didn't actually want to go to graduate school.
So I tried to just skip ahead and do it in undergrad. I went to GW, G-Dub in D.C. Oh, okay. G-Dub. G-Dub. G-Dub. Now, did you finish with a degree in anthropology and sociology? I finished in a degree in performance studies.
I got to actually like, I wrote my own situation. Got it. I created my reality. Wow. Does anybody call you K-Dub? Yes, especially because I went to G-Dub. Yeah. Okay.
Just thought of that. Now, wait, are you the only one with a college degree on this chat? Yeah. Sean. Sean, what's your excuse? How far did you go? I went four years and then I got an honorary doctorate, but I never graduated. I got one of those too.
You just show up. I got one of those. Yeah. If you go to the beach, they give you one. You can get one of those guys. Sean, I don't understand. You went for four years. How did you not?
Isn't that how long it takes? That's a great question. I was two or three courses shy and I just did not have any more gas than me to go. Yeah. I'm fascinated because you seem like a completer too. I spend a lot of time with you and you seem to have a tremendous amount of gas. Yeah, plenty of gas. I especially with the amount of tuna salad you eat, are you getting with plain chips?
And he likes to fuse with that glass of milk and off he goes. Nobody kills a bag of plain chips in a glass of 2% milk. Did you really drink a glass of milk? Is it real milk? Like just like cow's milk? Yeah, all every day. He's going to get in his Plymouth and drive off in a minute. But wait, Sean, so you ran out of gas two credits short, Will, how far did you get?
Oh, I made it half a year. Half of the first year. Half of a year. Yeah, that's right. Because college to me wasn't all just about the studies. It's about the social, it's about growing up, being on your own and like figuring stuff out. I'd already been out of the house.
You know, I went away to school first when I was 12. Yeah. You heard this story on the show about your clothes being taken to across town. I was like, that's kind of child abuse, no? Yeah. And then they made them plant trees and fix sewer pipes, too. Yeah. We did a lot of stuff.
I mean, look, it's not that bad, believe me. But I was 12 when I left, so, oh, you got a bogey. He's running around in your house. That's Emily. I know. The bogey locations go to two? Guys. Emily's actually, she has listened to your show longer than I have.
Hi, Emily. Hi, Emily. They're saying hi. Hi, Emily. She's saying hi. I'm geeking out. She's geeking out. Emily.
When I was at dinner with you guys, when I was at dinner for the cast for a live in front of a studio audience, I actually had not listened to a single episode yet and I was embarrassed. And so I faked having listened to a few episodes. And I was able to do so effectively. You told me you loved it. She's got skills. She's a professional liar. I was able to, well, I'm an actor.
Yeah. But I knew just from hearing Emily talk about it and also hearing my husband, Namdi, talk about it, I had enough context clues and, like, reference points to pretend that I had seen, but I hadn't. I hadn't watched and listened. And so then I went home and felt bad, so I started listening. And then I was like, this is the best podcast ever. That's okay.
Jason, tell Carrie how much you love Scandal every episode. Yeah, yeah. I've seen as many episodes of Scandal as you have seen of Arrested Development, Sean. Ooh. I have watched Ozark. Now, well, thank you. Now, what do you guys do about that? Because we all know a lot of people and are friends with a lot of people that do a lot
of stuff and you can't possibly see it all. You can't watch it all. Yeah. Do you feel bad about that? Do you lie about it? Do you make an effort? I'm just, I'm terrible about it. Well, I've just admitted that I lie sometimes, but I try not to.
Yeah. I just really lie. And now all her friends, it's out there as they know that she just lies and that's fine. What I do is, you know, what's hard is, Sean, you know, this one is like when you go, when somebody says, I'm doing, you know, I'm in a show on Broadway or I'm doing a play or whatever, I'm always reluctant to go because you have to go and say hi to the master. Well, now, Carrie, talk about that. Oh, yeah.
I've changed Will since we talked about that. Like, I know somebody, I won't say her name, very extremely, gigantically globally famous who came to one of my shows and she didn't come back and I was like, I get it. We don't really know each other. Why would she come back? It makes me spiral. Yeah. When somebody doesn't come back, I, and I'm, maybe that just means I'm, I'm an insecure
person. I, it freaks me out. No, but how do you know that they're there? Cause that's the part that is. They tell you. So listen her for. The house manager tells you. So Tracy, when you're doing a show on, in New York, I think specifically in New York or
is it in Chicago too, Shawnee? Anywhere. So you, you end up finding out if there's anybody who has a SAG card that's sitting in the audience and whether you've invited them or not. SAG card, Tracy sidebar, Tracy, that's a screen actor's guilt card. Double Tracy sidebar. So if they don't come back, like you have to go back and say that you love the show. Even if you don't know the people in the cast, I just found that, that ritual to be weird.
Well, that's what it means. So I don't want to lie. So I just, I'm like, I just end up not going to stuff cause I want to. Cause you don't want to go and not like what you see and then have to lie about it. Cause I, I'm a. Oh, aren't you a person of integrity? No, I'm not. But can't you, but can't you go to a, to a show, can't you go to a show without anybody
knowing that you're there? I mean, like. Yeah. Which is why I go into my character room. It depends on the show and the audience. Like for me, I could never in my life go to a show that has a black cast and not. Go backstage. Go backstage because they will know that I'm there.
But wait a minute. You're saying if you were in a show and somebody in the audience is, has a sad card and doesn't come back, you, you take that personally? Yeah. There's an actor who I knew had come to see a play I was in called American son and he did not come backstage and unbeknownst to him, I held it against him for like a year and a half. I was like, I, I just thought how, like why, it was, you know, why, why, did you ever run
into that actor and ask him? Well, I then found out because I'm friends with his wife that she was the only one who had come and that she was running straight to the airport afterward and that's why she texted me. And so I was like, oh my God, I've been like, he's been dead to me inside my heart, snubbing him at parties. Yeah. He's been dead to me for a year and a half for no reason, you know what I'm going to
start doing? He's going, taking in a lot of theater and making a point of not going backstage, hanging around outside a lot for a while and then leaving and then going like, not only did he not come back, but he fucking, he didn't even run off. He was here. He was, he was here for a while milling around. What I learned in that is that I have to be more generous, right? Like, and I try to be more generous in my attitude toward people, but that was a really
good reminder of like, you don't know what's going on in people's lives. Right. When somebody really stubs you to your face, you don't know if they just had a car accident or like it just was a reminder, like be generous. Yeah, yeah. The world does not revolve around you and your Broadway performance. You seem constantly happy, sunny. You don't seem like a, like a, like a dark person.
75|||是的，这真是一个很好的提醒，你永远不知道别人的生活里正在发生什么。确实。当有人真的当面顶撞你时，你并不知道他们是不是刚刚遭遇了车祸，或者这只是一个提醒，让你待人宽厚一些。对啊，对啊。世界可不会围着你和你的百老汇表演转。你看起来总是那么快乐、阳光。你可一点也不像个阴暗的人。
What, what, what, what, what would get the, what would get the real ire up in you? What? When are you the, when are you the nastiest? Finally, we're going to meet the real Carrie Walsh. No. Is it traffic? Is it people that cut you off from traffic? No, no.
什么，什么，什么，什么，什么能把你惹毛？什么？你什么时候最刻薄？终于，我们要见到真正的凯莉·华盛顿了。才怪。是因为交通吗？是因为有人在路上别你的车吗？不，不。
I'm not a traffic, because I'm not a very good driver. So I have to be generous when I'm driving. Yeah. What really pisses you off? You know what? Dishonesty, like to circle back, like if I feel like I'm being gaslit or people are keeping information from me in that way, you know how like people really like to infantilize actors? Like they don't want to talk to the talent, they don't want to tell talent things or like
我不怎么路怒，因为我开车技术不太好。所以开车时我必须得大度一点。对啊。到底是什么真的惹恼了你？你知道吗？是不诚实，就像刚才说的，如果我觉得自己被PUA了，或者有人故意对隐瞒信息，你知道人们有多喜欢把演员当小孩子看待吗？比如他们不想和演员沟通，不想把事情告诉演员，或者像
just in my life, throughout my life, whether it's through, because of my acting way, if I feel like people aren't being honest with me, it really upsets me. Yeah. This is what makes you a good producer, right? Yeah, maybe. Somebody who's like holding the information and then sort of disseminates it throughout the production, you understand what a, what a value that is and how bad it is when you're on the other side of that, not getting it.
只是在我的人生中，贯穿我的整个人生，不管是由于我的演员身份，如果我觉得人们对我不够诚实，我真的会很难过。对啊。这就是为什么你是个优秀的制片人，对吧？对，也许吧。那种把信息捂着不放，然后慢慢在整个制作过程中透露一点的人，你就会明白这有多大价值，而当你站在另一端、被蒙在鼓里时，这种感觉有多糟糕。
Carrie, by the way, I can relate to that. I'm like, tell it to me straight. Yeah. Yeah. Just let me know. Just let me fucking straight and let me, I'll decide how I react. By the way, honestly, Will, if you come to see me in something like, let's say, accidentally, you stumble upon a play that I met on Broadway, you don't know I'm in it.
凯莉，顺便说一句，我对此感同身受。我就喜欢：有话直说。对啊。对啊。直接告诉我吧。直接他妈的告诉我，至于我怎么反应，我自己决定。顺便说一句，说实话，威廉，如果你来看我的演出，比如说，纯属偶然，你无意中走进了一部我在百老汇演出的戏剧，你事先并不知道我在里面。
Yeah, sure. If you came backstage and you said, I'm not crazy about this one, it would, it would make me feel closer to you than you leaving and I, I appreciate the transparency. I'm making this pledge to you today. You're going to tell me when I suck. I will always be honest with you. I will always be straight up with you. Thank you.
对，当然。如果你走到后台对我说，这场演出的表现我不太满意，这会让我觉得跟你更亲近，总好过你悄悄离开而我一无所知，我很感激这份坦诚。我今天向你保证。我演得烂的时候你一定要告诉我。我一定会对你诚实的。我一定会对你直言不讳的。谢谢你。
About what I think about where you're at. And I want you to know that. Thank you. And forget performance on stage and in your life. Oh my God. This is amazing. Carrie, the worst thing, wait, really, the worst thing anybody could ever say when they come backstage, boy, it looks like you're having a lot of fun up there.
关于我对你现状的看法。我希望你知道这一点。谢谢你。抛开舞台上的表演和生活中的演出不谈。哦，天哪。这太棒了。凯莉，最糟糕的事情，等等，真的，当人们来到后台时，能说出的最糟糕的话就是：天哪，看起来你在上面玩得很开心啊。
That's the kiss of death. That is the worst. Or like, or they're like, you guys did that. That was, you did, wow, you did that. You did this how many times a week? Yeah. The thing too is it's so, you're so vulnerable. When you're on stage, you're so, there's no edit room.
那简直是死亡之吻。那是最糟糕的。或者说，或者他们会说：“你们居然演了这个。太……你们演了，哇，你们居然演了这个。你们一周要演多少次啊？”对啊。问题还在于，你太脆弱了。你在舞台上时，你是那么地……没有剪辑室。
There's no score to hide the moment that wasn't fully honest. Like you're just so vulnerable up there. So I think that's probably why it was also like a little more raw than usual. Yes. Now in the world of not being told everything that maybe they should be told in the world of series, television, Tracy, oftentimes actors will not be told how that particular season is going to end. Now, you're a producer on that show.
没有配乐来掩饰那些不够真诚的时刻。你在上面就是那么脆弱。所以我想这大概也是为什么它比平时还要更真实、更赤裸一点。是的。说到在电视剧《丑闻》的世界里，人们有时不会被告知所有他们或许应该知道的事情，特蕾西，通常演员们不会被告知这一季最终会以什么方式结束。现在，你也是该剧的制片人。
So you probably have more access to storylines, but have you had that instance with the head writer about, let me know what my finish line is as an actor so I can calibrate what the arc is to get there instead of waiting to read each episode piecemeal. Yeah. I was not a producer in the beginning of Scandal. I became a producer later on in the life of the show. And director. Yes, and director.
所以你大概能接触到更多剧情线，但你有没有遇到过这种情况：和首席编剧沟通说，“作为演员，让我知道我的终点线在哪里，这样我就可以校准通往那里的弧光，而不是等着一集一集地读剧本碎片。”对。在《丑闻》刚开始的时候我不是制片人。我是后来剧集播到中途才成为制片人的。还是导演。对，还是导演。
And my favorite example of not knowing was we had a guest star named Joe Morton. And Joe Morton is an actor I'm a huge fan of. He did an incredible John Sayles Film Club brother from another planet. Oh, I love Joe Morton. He's so good. So he's a stellar. And he came out. He was like the one guest star that came on our show that I called home to mom and dad
而对于“被蒙在鼓里”这件事，我最喜欢的例子是，我们曾有一位客串演员叫乔·莫顿。乔·莫顿是我非常崇拜的演员。他拍过约翰·塞尔斯导演的不可思议的电影《来自另一个星球的兄弟》。哦，我很喜欢乔·莫顿。他太棒了。所以他是个大牌明星。他来了。他是我们剧组唯一一个让我给爸妈打电话的客串明星
and was like, oh, I got Joe Morton's on the show. And I was never in scenes with him. He was always in scenes with these other characters on the show. And every table read, I'd be like, God, I really hope that we can do a scene together. And he'd be like, me too, me too. And I knew that he had been in talks to do Romeo and Juliet on Broadway. And he had dropped out of that to come to Scandal. And I was like, he doesn't even get any scenes with number one.
并且说：“哦，我跟你说，乔·莫顿来我们剧组了。”但我从来没跟他拍过对手戏。他总是跟剧组里其他角色拍对手戏。每次剧本围读时，我都想：天哪，我真希望能跟他在同一场戏里出现。他就会说：我也是，我也是。我知道他当时在商量去百老汇演《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。他为了来拍《丑闻》把那个推掉了。然后我就想：他甚至没有跟女主角的对手戏。
Like, why did he drop out of his play on Broadway? He's got no scenes with me. Like, why did he do that? And I just was super like, what's going on? At the end of the scene, the very final line of that season was I get in a car. Joe Morton is sitting across from me and he says hi. And I say with a question mark at the end, dad, because he was my father on the show. And he knew from the beginning, from his first phone call with Shonda Rhimes,
比如，他为什么要推掉百老汇的戏剧？他跟我连一场对手戏都没有。比如，他为什么要这么做？我就超级纳闷：这到底是怎么回事？在那场戏的最后，那一季的最后一句台词是我坐进了一辆车里。乔·莫顿坐在我对面，他说了一声“嗨”。然后我带着一个问号说：“爸爸？”因为他在剧里演我的父亲。而他从一开始、从他和珊达·莱梅斯的第一次电话沟通起，
he knew that he was going to be my dad. And I didn't know until our table read of that episode, like live in the room with everybody. It was incredible. Yeah, so wonderful. It would have been cool if they'd pulled like a Star Wars and didn't tell you until you were actually filming the scene, right? That would have been amazing.
他就知道自己要演我的父亲。而我直到那集剧本围读的时候才知道，就在房间里跟所有人一起。太不可思议了。是的，太棒了。如果他们能像《星球大战》那样，直到你真正拍那场戏时才告诉你，那不是很酷吗？那太神奇了。
Is that how it happens in the scene? Star Wars? Yeah, Empire Strikes Back. Well, do you mean in the movie, but not on set, right? No, on the set. Darth Vader just blurbed something else and then in post, they put, you are Luke, I am your father. No.
拍那场戏的时候是这样的吗？《星球大战》？对，《帝国反击战》。你是说在电影里，但不是在片场，对吧？不，在片场。达斯·维达随便嘟囔了点别的台词，然后后期制作时，他们才配上：“你就是卢克，我是你父亲。”才不是。
So that the crew didn't know nobody knew until the movie came out, right? Mark Hamill knew? I think Mark Hamill knew, yeah. Wow. Isn't that wild? They were trying to protect the crew from leaking that to the fan base. Yeah. I think that's what I said.
为了不让剧组人员泄露给粉丝群体，对吧？马克·哈米尔知道吗？我想马克·哈米尔是知道的，对。哇。是不是很疯狂？他们试图保护剧组人员，防止他们把秘密泄露给粉丝群。对。我想我当时说的就是这个。
I don't know. Hey, Sean, any more tidbits from fucking The Winter Circle? Seven years ago. Also, what about Chris Kline's audition process for Star Trek? Let's bring Scotty in to give us some light on that. Do you know that the bridge on the Enterprise actually wasn't a bridge at all? Was scandal the first thing that kind of changed your trajectory? Or was it something else that made people really take notice?
我不知道。嘿，肖恩，还有没有从“剧组老友圈”里传出来的什么八卦？七年前。还有，克里斯·克莱因当年为《星际迷航》试镜的过程是怎么样的？我们把斯科蒂请来给我们讲讲内幕吧。你知道进取号的舰桥其实根本就不是个舰桥吗？是《丑闻》这部剧改变了你的演艺生涯轨迹吗？还是有别的什么东西让人们真正开始注意到你？
Or do you think that that's the thing that really launched you? That was the thing. I mean, I had a really great film career before that because I had been in, like these Oscar nominated films. Like I had a joke that if you hired me to play your wife, you would win an Oscar because I was with Jamie Foxx and Ray and I was in Last King of Scotland with Whitaker and so I had done, but nobody connected that the girl from Save the Last Dance was the girl from Ray.
或者你认为那才是真正让你大红大紫的作品？就是这部剧。我是说，在那之前我其实有一段非常棒的电影生涯，因为我演过那些获得奥斯卡提名的电影。我曾经开过个玩笑说，如果你雇我演你老婆，你就能拿奥斯卡，因为我和杰米·福克斯合作了《灵魂歌王》，我还演了威 Whitaker 主演的《苏格兰末代独裁》。所以其实我拍过，但没人把《留住最后一支舞》里的那个女孩和《灵魂歌王》里的女孩联系起来。
I was kind of a character actor and it was sort of disappearing into these really fun, very different films with accents from all over the world. But TV is just different, especially before streaming. TV was a different beast where all of a sudden I was in people's living rooms every single week. How many people do you have in your life that you actually spend an hour with every week other than your shrink? Not a lot. So it's a very intimate relationship.
我算是个性格演员，而且我总是能融入到这些非常有趣、风格迥异、带有世界各地口音的电影中。但电视就是不一样，尤其是流媒体出现之前。电视完全是另一码事，突然之间，我每周都会出现在人们的客厅里。除了你的心理医生之外，你生活中到底有几个人是你每周真的会花一个小时去相处的？没有几个。所以这是一种非常亲密的关。
I'm talking to you, Sean. I'm talking to myself and myself. So it did definitely changed my, like it changed, you know, sort of the level of, how I walked in the world maybe or like level of fame or whatever. Yeah. And were you scared to step in a role of leadership like that? Or was it finally like, was it like finally, oh my God, this is like what I've been waiting for to be like the number one on the call sheet kind of thing?
我在跟你说话呢，肖恩。我在跟自己和我的心说话。所以它确实改变了我的……比如它改变了你在世间行走时的某种姿态，或者说改变了名气的高度之类的。对。那你当时害怕踏入那样一个领导者的角色吗？还是说你终于觉得——就像是终于，“哦，天哪，这正是我一直等待的，成为演职员表上排名第一的主演”那种感觉？
Well, I really, there was all this pressure because at the time there was all this talk, every interview was about the fact that in almost 40 years there had not been a black woman as the lead of a network drama. Every article in the beginning, that's what. And so, and I was like 37 or something at the time. So in my lifetime, I had never seen a black woman as the lead of a network drama. And so that's all my pressure was my fear of like, if I screw this up, they're not going to let another woman of color be the lead of a network drama for another 40 years.
嗯，其实当时有各种各样的压力，因为那时所有人都在谈论这件事，每次采访都在讨论这样一个事实：在将近40年的时间里，竟然没有一个黑人女性担任过电视网黄金档剧集的第一主角。一开始所有的文章都在谈论这个。所以，而我当时大概37岁左右。所以在我有生之年，从来没见过哪个黑人女性担任过电视网剧集的第一主角。所以当时我所有的压力都来自于这种恐惧：如果我把这事搞砸了，未来40年内都不会再有另一个有色人种女性能成为电视网剧集的主角了。
Like I knew that we had to get it right. And I just had to work as hard as I'd ever worked on anything in my life. But luckily I've worked with amazing number ones. Like Jamie Foxx is the best number one in the business. No offense to you other number ones on here, but he's just the king. No one's better than Jamie Foxx. Jango Ray, like having worked with him in those, he's just a fun, he's so generous. He's a team leader.
我知道我们必须把这部剧拍好。我必须付出比我一生中做过的任何事情都要努力的努力。但幸运的是，我合作过非常棒的第一主演。比如杰米·福克斯就是这个行业里最棒的第一主演。无意冒犯在座的各位其他第一主演，但他绝对是王者。没有人比杰米·福克斯更棒了。《被解救的姜戈》、《灵魂歌王》，能和他在这些作品里合作，他真的是个有趣、极其大方的人。他是团队领袖。
He's a coach. He's a cheerleader. He's everybody's dad. And so you picked stuff from him. Yeah, I tried to collect like Forrest Whitaker is a beautiful number one. Julia Stiles is an incredible number one. Like I just tried to remember the things that I admired about the leaders. Love Julia.
他是个教练。他是啦啦队长。他是每个人的老爸。所以你从他身上学到了很多东西。对，我试着汲取经验。比如福里斯特·惠特克是一个极好的第一主演。朱丽娅·斯蒂尔斯也是一个不可思议的第一主演。我只是努力记住那些我所钦佩的领导者身上的特质。我很喜欢朱丽娅。
The good leaders. She's so great. So great. Oh my God, Jango and Shane is one of my favorite movies of all time. You are unbelievable in that. And I've seen it so many times. It's, it's always Quentin has Quentin Tarantino has is great at the theme of revenge. Right.
优秀的领导者。她太棒了。太棒了。哦，天哪，《被解救的姜戈》是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。你在里面的表演简直难以置信。我看了不知道多少遍。昆汀·塔伦蒂诺非常擅长处理复仇这个主题。
And that thing I watched whenever I watched that movie, it's disturbing to see you. That character. It's so disturbing. Any kind of fun Quentin stories. I mean, I love that he inserted himself in there and that one scene. It was so fantastic. Wait, which one? I forget.
每当我看到那部电影里你的那个角色时，都会觉得很不舒服。太令人不安了。有没有什么有趣的昆汀的幕后故事？我很喜欢他在那场戏里亲自客串出镜。简直太精彩了。等等，哪一场？我忘了。
I got a call. I was asleep in my apartment in New Orleans. We were like halfway through filming. And I got a call at like two or three in the morning and I pick up the phone. It's like, I was like, hello. And I hear Leo de Caprio and Jamie Foxx being like, yo, we need to talk. And I was like, what's happening? And they were like, Quinn wants to be in the movie.
我接到了一个电话。当时我在新奥尔良的公寓里睡觉。我们拍摄进度刚进行到一半左右。我在两三点的时候接到电话，我接起电话，我说“喂”，然后我听到莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和杰米·福克斯的声音说：“哟，我们得谈谈。”我就问：“发生什么事了？”他们说：“昆汀想在电影里演个角色。”
I was like, what? So at that like unfolded in the middle of shooting, we were all shocked, but it was great. He was. Yeah. So Jay just remind you in the, in the movie, he intercepts like the transfer of the, of the collected slaves, right? Yeah. And, and, and freeze them or something.
我说：“什么？”所以这事就在拍摄中途发生了，我们所有人都震惊了，但结果很棒。他是。对啊。杰，提醒你一下，在电影里，他拦截了……比如运送那些被抓捕的奴隶的队伍，对吧？对，然后把他们解救了什么的。
I can't remember. I'm so bad about remembering movies. I swear. Me too. I don't remember. Last week and forget the entire thing. Same. Same.
我记不清了。我对记电影情节太不在行了。真的。我也是。我不记得了。上周刚看过的电影转头就能忘得精光。一样。一样。
Even movies. I've been in. I don't remember movies. I've been in. I don't remember. I like to think it's for a positive reason that like maybe we're so good about getting completely inside that world that once you leave that world, it, it stays over there. I don't, I don't know.
甚至连我自己演过的电影我都不记得。我宁愿往好的方面想，也许是因为我们太投入那个世界了，一旦你离开了那个世界，它就永远留在那边了。我不知道，我不知道。
You don't remember. It's kinda like, it's like, you know what I mean, do you have an easy time memorizing lines though? Yeah. Jason does And do they stay with you? Or do you forget them? No, I can drop them just as easily as I, as I learned them.
你不记得了。这有点像……你知道我的意思吗？不过你记台词容易吗？对。杰森也是。那台词会留在你脑子里吗？还是你会忘掉？不，我忘台词跟学台词一样快。
But like it seems like all my memory skills have just been channeled into that one very narrow lane. It's, it's not, it's not great. Yeah. And now, a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show. Kair, what if I had, if I answered you, I mean, if I asked you this question
不过感觉我所有的记忆力都倾注在那一条非常狭窄的赛道上了。这可不太好。对。现在，让我们听听广告赞助商的话。好了，言归正传。凯莉，如果我问你这样一个问题
and you had to think of something really, really fast. Okay. Who's one or two of your favorite actors of all time that you worked with? Meryl Streep. And, um... Controversial. Yeah, well, I'm being honest.
而且你必须立刻马上想出一个答案。好的。在你合作过的所有演员中，你最喜欢的历史前一两位演员是谁？梅丽尔·斯特里普。还有……很有争议。对啊，我是说实话。
Not a lot of people agree with you on that whole talent assessment thing. What TikToks has she been? Have we seen her on a TikTok? What TikToks has she been on? And, I mean, it's hard. There's so many. You can't talk, Jamie Foxx. I love that that was the first one.
没多少人会同意你对那个演技评估的看法。她拍过什么TikTok视频吗？我们在TikTok上见过她吗？她上过什么TikTok？而且，这太难了。人太多了。你不能不提杰米·福克斯。我很高兴第一个说的就是他。
And Jamie. I love Jamie. Yeah. Yeah, I just love him. I love him. What was your first paid acting gig? My first paid acting gig. I played a cheerleader.
还有杰米。我太喜欢杰米了。对啊。对啊，我就是爱他。你第一份有报酬的表演工作是什么？我第一份有报酬的表演工作。我演了一个啦啦队员。
I don't think I had a name. I think I was like cheerleader number two in an ABC After School special called My Special Angel. Oh, wow. I think. Who was the angel? I don't know.
我想我连名字都没有。我大概是在一部名叫《我的特殊天使》的ABC放学后特别节目里演了“啦啦队员二号”之类的角色。哦，哇。我想是这样的。谁是那个天使？我不知道。
I don't remember. I may have done a PSA or something before that. God, After School specials. Remember those? After School specials. Jason, did you ever do one? An After School special? I don't know if I did an After School special.
我不记得了。在此之前我可能拍过什么公益广告之类的。天哪，放学后特别节目。还记得那些吗？放学后特别节目。杰森，你演过吗？放学后特别节目？我不知道我有没有演过放学后特别节目。
I did a few movies of the week. Those were good. Remember, there used to be a CBS, NBC, ABC. They all used to make their own movies in it, right? Yeah. Sunday night. Yeah. Yeah. Now it's like Hallmark Channel does those in lifetime. That's great.
我倒是拍过几部周播电影。那些还挺不错的。还记得吗，以前哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）、全国广播公司（NBC）、美国广播公司（ABC）。他们过去都会自己拍电影，对吧？对。周日晚上。对。对。现在嘛，也就是 Hallmark 频道和 Lifetime 频道在拍那些。挺不错的。
Wait, so, Kara, and the other thing that I went on and on about before, but I'm going to do it again because you're so amazing, was American Son on Broadway, which I didn't get to see because I was doing something. Yes. But I later to see it on Netflix. From Sis Promises? So, first of all, it was such an ingenious idea
等等，凯莉，还有一件事我之前喋喋不休地说过，但我还要再说一遍，因为你实在是太棒了，那就是百老汇的《美国之子》，我当时因为有别的安排没能去看。是的。不过我后来在 Netflix 上看了。来自 Sis Promises 的作品？所以，首先，这是一个多么巧妙的主意
to film the play like that. It was like a hybrid of stage and film. I'd never seen anything like it. Your performance was off the chart. Like it was amazing. You're allowed to do that? You can film a play on Broadway? No, it was.
把这部戏剧拍成那样。它就像是舞台与电影的结合体。我从来没见过这样的作品。你的表演简直无与伦比。就像是太棒了。这也可以吗？你可以在百老汇拍摄戏剧吗？不，不是的。
No. So, really, the reason I came up with that idea was because I loved producing. I love producing. I fell in love with producing at Scandal. And the first film I produced was a film called Confirmation for HBO where I played Anita Hill. And then I fell in love with it.
不，其实，我想出那个主意的原因是因为我喜欢制片。我喜欢制片。我在拍《丑闻》时爱上了制片工作。我制片的第一部电影是 HBO 的一部叫《确认》的电影，我在里面饰演阿 Anita Hill。然后我就深深地爱上了制片。
And so, they came to me to do this play on Broadway. The producers and I said, sure, I'll be in it if I can help produce. But on Broadway, producing really just means finding money. You get to be a creative producer as well, but I was like, oh, I don't do the financing thing. I haven't done that. But I was like, okay, I'll jump in and I'll try.
所以，他们找我来演百老汇的这部戏。制片人们问我，我说当然行，如果能让我参与制片的话，我就演。但在百老汇，制片其实主要意味着找资金。你也可以成为一个创意制片人，但我当时就想：哦，我不搞融资那一套，我没做过这个。不过我想：好吧，我来试试看，我会加入的。
And one of the ideas I had for how I could make the money to help produce the play was like, what if we film it? What if we can sell it to a streamer? Sell the rights. So Netflix, you know, Ted read it and loved it. But, Jay, it was filmed not in a proscenium. It was filmed. We built us on stages.
我当时想到的能筹集资金来协助制作这部戏的点子之一就是：如果我们把它拍成电影怎么样？如果我们把它卖给流媒体平台呢？卖掉版权。所以 Netflix 公司的泰德读了剧本并且非常喜欢。但是，杰，它可不是在镜框式舞台上拍摄的。它是……我们在摄影棚里搭建了布景。
We built on stages. We kind of like built a fourth wall to complete the room because the play all takes place in one room. And so we just completed the room and shot it on a stage in the one room. Your performance was just mind blowing. It means so much coming from you. Thank you.
我们在摄影棚里搭建了布景。我们有点像是搭建了一面“第四堵墙”来让这个房间完整，因为整部戏剧都发生在一个房间里。所以我们把那个房间补全，然后在一个摄影棚的那个单间里拍摄。你的表演简直太震撼了。能听到你这么说对我意义重大。谢谢你。
It was. Not that much, but I really want to see it. I really, really... By the way... It's on Netflix. I'm going to watch it. Do you have an account? Well, I share it with like 20 people, but I'm going to watch it.
确实如此。虽然没那么夸张，但我真的很想看。我真的、真的……顺便说一句……它在 Netflix 上。我要去看。你有账号吗？呃，我跟大概20个人共用一个，不过我会去看的。
And then I'm going to get your number from Sean. Okay, good. And I'm going to text Aaron from Kimmel what I was going to say. You might be texting Aaron. And I'm going to be honest. Now, Kerry, where are you right now? Are you home?
然后我会找肖恩要你的电话号码。好的，没问题。我会发短信给吉米·金梅尔节目的亚伦……我要说的是，你可能会给亚伦发短信。而且我会说实话。现在，凯莉，你现在在哪里？你在家吗？
Are you traveling? Are you on location somewhere? I'm not home. I'm on location because I'm doing... We're doing a new YouTube series at my company called The Street You Grew Up On. And it's something I started in pandemic because my production company is named after the street
你在旅行吗？还是在某个外景地？我不在家。我在外景地，因为我在拍……我们在我的公司制作一档全新的 YouTube 系列节目，名叫《你成长的街道》。这是我在疫情期间开始做的一个项目，因为我的制作公司就是以我母亲在布朗克斯区长大的那条街命名的——辛普森街。当我们还是孩子的时候，我们经常听到关于辛普森街上发生的各种恶作剧的故事。所以我觉得那就是我的“很久很久以前”。我祖父母是通过埃利斯岛来到美国的。他们从加勒比地区移民过来，住在布朗克斯区。辛普森街就像是一切开始的地方，
that my mother grew up on in the Bronx, Simpson Street. And when we were kids, we used to hear all these stories about all the shenanigans that went on in Simpson Street. So I feel like that's my once upon a time. My grandparents came to the states through Ellis Island. They immigrated from the Caribbean and they lived in the Bronx. And Simpson Street was like where it all started,
梦想起航的地方。所以我采访那些我真正喜欢、尊重和钦佩的人——除了你们三位之外——聊聊他们成长的街道。听完你们三位，我哪还有地方发挥啊？不知道。所以，是的，我问他们关于他们长大的街道以及他们的童年是什么样的。
where the dreams began. So I interview people that I really like and respect and admire other than the three of you and about the street that they grew up on. How do you have room after the three of us? I don't know. So yeah, and I asked them questions about the street they grew up on and what their childhoods were like.
那真的很酷。对啊，挺有意思的。所以我们今天得拍好几个这样的采访。你知道我一直想做什么吗？顺便说一句，如果你想要的话，这个创意可以送给你。一个人吃掉整整一盒冰激凌，然后紧接着再吃一盒？对。
That's really cool. Yeah, it's fun. So we're doing a bunch of them today. You know what I always wanted to do, but you can, by the way, you can have this idea if you want. Eat an entire carton of ice cream by yourself and then do it again right after? Yeah.
然后呢？是的，然后呢？这有点类似于那个创意，就是去拜访一位名人成名之前住过的地方，对吧？比如回到他们的公寓去敲门，采访现在住在那里的人，然后交换一下
And? Yes, and? It's like similar to that idea, which is go visit with a celebrity the places they lived before they made it, right? So like go back to their apartment and knock on the door and interview the family that lived there, that lives there now and kind of swap stories
关于你当年住在那里时的生活故事。我觉得这会非常酷。所有的公寓什么的。我有一个梦想，也许下一季可以和我们的嘉宾一起去一些外景地。那些故事简直难以置信。但想想看，你能从那些住在那里的人口中听到多少故事啊。对，就是现在住在那里的人。
about how you lived when you were there. And I think it would be really cool. All the apartments and whatever. I have a dream about maybe next season going to some of the locations with our guests. The stories are incredible. But think about the stories you'd get from the people that lived there. Yeah, the people that live there now.
你简直就像是我们的下一个芭芭拉·沃尔特斯。等等，那么第一个问题，我问所有人的第一个问题就是了解他们成长的街道的名字。我问的是他们的“色情片名”。所以我想知道你第一只宠物的名字和你长大的街道的名字。所以可以吗，我想问你们三个人的“色情片名”，
You're like, you're like our next Barbara Walters. Wait, so the first, the first question, the first question that I ask everybody is to learn the name of the street that they grew up on. I asked their porn name. So I want to know the name of your first pet and the street you grew up on. So can I, I want to ask you three your porn names,
不是你们过去用过的真正的色情片名，因为你们养过那些宠物。宠物的名字加上你长大的第一条街。我养的第一只宠物是一只肉桂色的小鸟。所以它叫西妮（Siney），或者她叫这个。然后第一条街是爱默生（Emerson），西妮·爱默生。就是这样。
not your actual porn names that you have used in the past because you have those pets. Pat's first name and your first pet. First pet for me was a little bird that was a cinnamon color. And so he was called Siney or she was so. And then the first street was Emerson, Siney Emerson. There you go.
听起来挺可爱的。甜美的西妮·爱默生。那是我的中间名。爱默生是我的中间名。西妮·爱默生在这类色情片里主要负责接受。没有什么付出的部分。基本上全是接盘侠。她很擅长这个。
That's kind of cute. Sweet little Siney Emerson. That's my middle name. Emerson's my middle name. Siney Emerson receives a lot in these porn. Not a lot of giving. Mostly catching. She's good at it.
对啊。染上禽流感。非常被动。威廉，你呢？我们养过一只猫。好吧，抓住我。你不用解释这个故事。直接说你第一只宠物的名字和街道的名字。
Yep. Catches bird flu. Real passive. Will, what about you? We had a cat. Well, catch me. You don't have to explain the story. Just what's the name of your first pet on the screen.
他非得聊那只蠢鸟。又是接受又是接盘的。你们俩简直就像我的孩子。他非得说这个。应该是米努·埃德加（Minu Edgar）。米努·埃德加。现在米努·埃德加在这类色情片里要经受不少折磨。西妮看到米努走过来就开始逃跑。
He got to talk about the stupid fucking bird. And receiving and catching up. You guys are like my kids. He got to do it. It would be Minu Edgar. Minu Edgar. Now Minu Edgar is giving a lot of pain on these porn. Siney sees Minu coming and just starts running.
我的是乔什·瓦利（Josh Valley）。什么动物会叫乔什？你宠物的名字叫乔什。我狗的名字叫Josh，我住在Valley大道。你狗的名字叫Josh。你为什么给狗起名叫Josh？我没起啊。
Mine's Josh Valley. Josh Valley. What kind of animals named Josh? Your pet's name was Josh. My dog's name was Josh and I lived on Valley Avenue. Your dog's name was Josh. Why did you name your dog Josh? I didn't name it.
我爸起的。哦，这家伙。不，凯莉，你的呢？我的。最棒的是我为了这个系列采访了我妈妈。我说：“妈，你以前没养过宠物吧？”她说：“不，不，我们养过。我们养过一只叫‘大男孩’（Big Boy）的猫。”
My dad did. Oh, this guy. No, Carrie, what was yours? Mine. The best was that I interviewed my mom for this series. And I was like, you didn't have any pets, mom, did you? And she said, no, no, we did. We had a cat named Big Boy.
所以，我妈的“色情片名”是大男孩·辛普森（Big Boy Simpson）。太绝了。西妮直接笑喷了。我养过两只仓鼠，分别叫“恶作剧”（Trick）和“招待”（Treat）。我是在帕格斯利大道（Pugsley Avenue）长大的。所以是 Trick and Treat Pugsley。同样非常活跃。Trick and Treat Pugs，哇，太酷了。
So my mom's, my mother's poor name is Big Boy Simpson. That's fantastic. Siney just exploded. I had Hamsters named Trick and Treat. And I grew up on Pugsley Avenue. So Trick and Treat Pugsley. Also very active. Trick and Treat Pugs is, wow, that's so cool.
我很喜欢这个。这就是你开启这个系列节目的方式。我们每集节目都是这样开始的。太棒了。我太喜欢了。那么，在完美的平衡状态下，你工作的频率是怎样的？你在家的时间有多少？比如说，你一年里希望有多少时间处于无所事事的状态？
I love that. And that's how you launch into this series. That's how we start each episode. That's great. I love that. So in a perfect balance, then how often are you working? How often are you home? Like how often do you like to be bored throughout the year?
因为我认为无聊是通往放松的途径。如果你能试着找到的话。我觉得你说得对。所以我最近不是很放松，因为我一直没有机会好好无聊一下。这成了我最近心理治疗的主要课题：如何安排更多开放式的、属于创造力的时间，因为我是一个行动派。我真的很喜欢忙碌，喜欢完成各种事情，喜欢那种觉得自己很有成效、对世界有用的感觉。
Because I think boredom is the route to relaxation. If you can try to find. I think you're right. So I'm not very relaxed these days because I haven't been very bored. This is the main theme of my therapy these days is figuring out how to schedule more like open creative time because I am a doer. Like I really like to be busy and I like to accomplish things and feel like I'm being productive and useful in the world.
但我也非常非常爱我的家人，喜欢和他们共度时光，喜欢能在海滩上读一读小说。我是“海滩读书小分队”的成员。我确实喜欢。谢谢你。我确实喜欢。我是这队的。那简直太糟糕了。
But I also really, really love my family and spending time with them and being able to read a book on the beach. I'm with the reading the book on the beach team. I do. Thank you. I do. I'm with that. That's the worst.
甚至听听有声书也行。肖恩，如果你在一个漂亮的凉棚里呢？四周都有透气舒适的面料环绕着你。头顶上有一个漂亮的屋顶。我们还有一杯冰凉爽口的饮料。你穿着百慕大短腿裤和夏威夷衫。我在思考。我知道你想问什么。
Or even listen an audio book. Sean, what if you were in like in a nice cabana, right? We got nice breathable fabric around three sides of you. We got a nice roof over the top. We've got some sort of a frosty drink. You're in Bermuda shorts and a Hawaiian shirt. I'm going to be thinking. I know what you're asking.
那我能看书吗？对。而且你还有一个不错的电扇吹着你。也许甚至还有一台便携电视。那种带喷雾功能的电扇。哦，相信我。肖恩这辈子就没见过他讨厌的电扇。好吧。
Could I read a book then? Yeah. And you got a nice fan on you. Maybe there's even a portable TV. The fan that has the mist. Oh, believe me. Sean's never met a fan he didn't like. Okay.
肖恩，那样的话就行得通了。对吧？好吧，让我……我要问你同样的问题。你知道的。可能还是不行，因为我会被美景和微风分散注意力，然后我就会想去干点别的，而不是坐着。你就是坐不住。但还有一件事。
Sean, that would work. Right? Well, let me, I'm going to ask you the same question. You know that. It probably wouldn't because I'd be distracted right by the beauty and the breeze and I'd want to like go do something, not sit. You can't sit still. But here's the other thing.
但这又不是一整天。这只是你一天当中抽出的一小段时间，可以用来彻底放空。凯莉，你需要明白的是，肖恩根本坐不住，也无法停止烦躁不安、小动作不断，同时还要看一本书。无论在哪里。不过，我曾跟他一起坐过一趟飞往伊斯坦布尔的航班，单程就要14个小时，他在飞机上玩了一整路该死的《糖果传奇》。对。
But it's not the whole day. It's just like a section of the day where you get the disappearing too. Kerry, what you need to understand is Sean can't sit still and not fidget like and do that and read a book. Anywhere. However, I have been with him on a return 14 hours each way flight to LA to Istanbul where he played Candy Crush the entire fucking time. Yeah.
所以他完全可以……顺便说一句，把那玩意儿叫作“游戏”简直就像是……你知道的，就像把一本小册子叫作……简直就像是：你为什么不直接把舱门拉开，在大西洋上空的某个地方跳下去算了，然后像：我怎么可能对这东西持续八小时保持专注？我永远不会忘记那趟航班，因为他们给我们喂了八万磅的食物。就像是，对。他们根本停不下来。
So he can just do, by the way, calling that a game is like fucking, you know, like calling a pamphlet. It's just like, Why don't you just rip the door open and jump out somewhere over the Atlantic and just like, how could I still be engaged with this eight hours? I'll never forget that flight too because they fed us 80,000 pounds of food. Like, yeah. Just did not stop serving.
你们当时坐在头等舱吗？我记得，我记得吃过……对不起，我记得有那么一觉睡了大概六个小时，然后醒来心想：哦，天哪，我看着……肖恩还在玩。还是同一个姿势。难道你的冥想方式就是玩《糖果传奇》吗？放空自己，就像是……我太喜欢了。对。那就是让我上瘾的地方，能获得那种内心的宁静。
Were you guys sitting up front? I remember, I remember eating, I'm sorry, I remember sleeping like for like six hours at one point and then waking up and being like, oh man, I really, I'm looking and Sean's got it. Same position. Is that your meditation is candy crush your meditation check out and like, I love that. Yeah. That's, that's what I'm addicted to is like the solace of that.
好吧，他们为了那些游戏确实下了苦功。所有这些游戏都在努力控制你的大脑。我懂。顺便说一句，他们得逞了。真的。哦，天哪。别担心。事实证明，他们……他们声称其实也没什么好掌控的。
Well, they work hard on that. They work hard all those games to, to control your brain. I know. By the way, they can have it. And right. Oh my God. Don't worry. Turns out they, they claim there wasn't much to grab.
他们能拿走的都拿走了。他们真的把我的大脑给“糖果传奇”化了。好了。所以听着，我们很快就会让你休息的。我保证，但我希望你聊聊那个叫《预言》（Prophecy）的播客。那是什么？听起来太棒了。你在里面担任主演。
They took what they could. They really candy crushed my brain. All right. So listen, we're going to let you go soon. I promise, but I want you to talk about the prophecy podcast. What is it? Cause it sounds amazing. You're starring in it.
你是该剧的执行制片人（EP）。主演阵容包括劳伦斯·菲什伯恩、金大贤和大卫·奥伊罗。哦，对。我想……所以我也想感谢我的许多……我身边的许多合作伙伴，他们甚至比我自己更希望我来做这个播客，我是说，我真的是个超级粉丝，但是我的团队里有一个叫威廉的家伙，他说：我们有一个和米我在一起的播客叫《预言》。所以你……是的，这名字挺烂的，但他听起来很聪明。
You're EP on it. And it stars Lawrence Fishburne, Daniel Day Kim and David Oye Loa. Oh yeah. I want it. So I also, I want to thank so many of, a lot of the folks that I work with wanted me to do this podcast even more than I, I mean, I really, I'm such a Uber fan, but my, there's a guy on my team named Will who was like, we have a podcast with me on prophecy. So you, yeah, it's a bad name, but he sounds brilliant.
威廉当时说：因为我们在做播客，所以我们必须上最好的播客。这就是为什么我这么高兴能跟你们聊天的部分原因。所以《预言》这部作品，它是一部在 Audible 上的叙事广播剧。这是一个非常酷的概念。这个概念是：如果《圣经》不是一本记录人们认为过去发生过的事情的文献，而是一本关于未来将要发生的事情的预言性文献呢？所以我饰演这个女性，一个最终怀孕的女科学家，但我不知道
Will was like, because we're doing a podcast, we have to be on the best podcast. So that is part of why I'm so happy to be talking to you guys. So prophecy is it's a, it's a narrative podcast on audible. It's a really cool concept. The concept is like, what if the Bible wasn't a document about things that people thought happened in the past, but what if it was a prophetic document about things that were going to happen in the future? And so I play this woman, this scientist who winds up being pregnant and I don't know
这是怎么回事，因为我丈夫根本让我怀不上孕。我们心知肚明。而且，我的名字叫弗吉尼亚·玛丽琳（Virginia Marylin），听起来就像“圣母玛利亚”（Virgin Mary）。还有一个叫约拿的科学家，他遭遇了鲸鱼袭击，却在鲸鱼肚子里活了三天。还有一个叫丹尼尔的动物学家，最后落入了狮子坑，但狮子没有咬死他。这就像是这些《圣经》中的事件不断涌现，这到底意味着什么，我们该如何
how cause my husband can't impregnate me. We know that. And, and my name is Virginia Marylin, so like Virgin Mary. And there's a, there's a scientist named Jonah who gets in a situation with a whale and stays alive for three days. And there's a guy named Daniel who's a zoologist who ends up in a lion's den and they don't kill him. And it's kind of like these biblical happenings are popping up and what does it mean and how
应对？这非常酷。这绝对是个好主意。有点科幻色彩。非常强烈。而且这个项目已经被买下版权了吗？我们……好吧，我之所以想……我与 Audible 签署了一项协议，要在叙事音频领域创作播客。
do we deal with it? It's very cool. It's a great idea. Like sci-fi. Very much. And has that yet been optioned? We, well, a part of why I wanted to, I'm in this deal with audible to create podcasts in the narrative space.
我觉得这是测试故事并搞清楚这究竟是一个限定剧还是电影的好方法。我觉得这个项目很适合拍成电影。很棒的节目。很酷。所以这个想法是，如果它反响不错的话，会把它拍成一部真正的电视剧吗？对。对。
And I feel like it's a really good way to test out story and figure out, is this limited? Is it a film? I think this one is a film. Great show. It's cool. And is the idea then to like, maybe if it goes well, make it up actual series? Yeah. Yeah.
或者是电影。我觉得它可能会拍成三部曲电影。那真的很酷。我不确定。我会看的。对。我也会看。我是说，让我看看我的日程表。
Or film. I think it might be a trilogy of films. That's really cool. I'm not sure. I would watch that. Yeah. I would watch it too. I mean, let me look at my schedule.
你们……拍摄周期有多长？从什么时候开始？哦，哦，你想演吗？对。威廉，你对自拍试镜怎么看？我想演个他妈的男一号……凯莉，你刚才一直在谈论演员排名第一的主演，我就在想：她到底在铺垫什么？她到底想干嘛？
What are you, how long is the shoot? Start, start. Oh, oh, do you want to be in it? Yeah. How do you feel about self-taping, Will? I want to be fucking number, Carrie, you were talking about number ones and I'm like, what is she working towards here? What is she trying?
然后我就想：哦，来了。推销来了。所以她先是谈到第一主演，接着推销她的剧集——其实也可以拍成电影——然后她直直地看着我。我就想：来吧。好吧，告诉我，这样吧，你知道我在 CAA 经纪公司吧，随便抛几个数字过来，让我看看日程安排。
And I'm like, oh, here it comes. Here comes the pitch. So the number one, then she pitches the show and it could be a movie actually and then she looks right at me. I'm like, here we go. All right. So tell me, I'll tell you what, do you know I'm at CAA, launch some numbers our way and let me look at the schedule.
给我们点反应的机会。让我看看。我们会围绕你的高尔夫行程来安排拍摄的。难以置信。我们会围绕你的高尔夫来拍。对。确实如此。这倒是个好主意。
Give us something to react to. Let me see. We'll fit it around your golf. Unbelievable. We'll shoot around your golf. Yeah. That's true. That's a good point.
凯莉·华盛顿，你知道我有多爱你。你收到邮件了。我爱你。你是最棒的。我太爱你们了。你们太棒了。我爱你们所有人，我和你们一样，都是超级、超级粉丝。我能说吗，作为经常做这种事的人——
Carrie Washington, you know how much I love you. You got the email. I love you. You're the best. I love you so much. You guys are amazing. I love you all and I'm a massive, massive fan as you all are. Can I just say, I want to say as somebody who like, this is what we do all the time.
我们必须跟各种人交流，做这些采访。这感觉太真实了。每次我听的时候都能听出来，大家都不想挂断你们的电话。他们就觉得……他们太喜欢这些采访了。气氛太好了。他们根本不想离开。再见。人们都不想离开。
We have to talk to people and we do these interviews. It's so real. I can tell every time I listen that people are, they don't want to get off with you. They're like, they love these interviews. It's a good time. They don't want to leave. Bye. People don't want to leave.
再见。她做到了。太完美了。她太棒了。她真是太棒了。太棒了。哇。从来没有人这样做过自我宣传。
Bye. She did it. That was perfect. She's so fine. She's so fine. So good. Wow. No one has ever self-fied before.
哇。太棒了。凯莉·华盛顿，哥伦比亚特区（DC）。凯莉·华盛顿（Kerry Washington, DC）。哦，她把整个哥伦比亚特区都占了。对啊。对啊。所以她是凯莉·华盛顿。
Wow. That was great. Kerry Washington, DC. Kerry Washington. Oh, she had the full district in Columbia. Yeah. Yeah. So it's Kerry Washington.
哇。没多少人知道这个。所以她简直是个完美梦幻嘉宾。凯莉·华盛顿其实也是个很棒的名字，可以用来拍一部……比如侦探剧。凯莉·华盛顿，就像那是她角色的名字一样。对，凯莉·华盛顿。
Wow. Not a lot of people know that. So she's a dream. Kerry Washington would actually be the great name for a, like just like a detective series too. Kerry Washington, like that's the name of her character. Yes. Kerry Washington.
不，不，不。但你要拼写作 C-A-R-R-Y，就像是“努力撑下去”（carrying）。就像她挑起了大梁。对啊。就像她把所有人扛在肩上。对啊。对啊。她得挑大梁。
No, no, no. But you'd spell it C-A-R-R-Y because trying to like keep watching Kerry. Like she's carrying a lot. Yeah. Like trying to keep people cold on her shoulders. Yeah. Yeah. She's got to carry one.
哦天哪。顺便说一句，我们呼叫她一下。让她回来。你能把她叫回来吗？对。我们打个电话。好吧，肖恩没有她的电话，但是……给发邮件吧，肖恩。
Oh my gosh. By the way, let's page her. Get her back on. Can you call her back? Yeah. We'll call. Well, Sean doesn't have her number, but. Email her, Sean.
难道这不是最蠢的故事吗？肖恩，那个故事太他妈……太精彩了。简直让人尴尬。对你来说太有失水准了。顺便说一句，你刚才直接把话题跳过去了。我很喜欢亚伦当时也在场。对啊。
Isn't that the dumbest story? Sean, that story is so fucking. It's so good. I mean, it's so embarrassing. It's so unbranded for you. By the way, you just made the leap. I love that Aaron was on the other end of that. Yeah.
而且亚伦……亚伦是另一个人。你当时……很显然亚伦知道这个故事。我想我跟他讲过，对。对。谁才是最棒的？这太棒了。等一下。
And that Aaron, Aaron's the other person. Did you? And obviously Aaron knows the story. I think I told her, yeah. Yeah. Who's the best? It's so good. Wait a minute.
她有多棒？而且她那么……那么讨人喜欢，那么聪明，那么华丽，那么有才华，那么真实又自然。对啊。我知道我对我们的每个嘉宾都这么说，但……我就是停不下来。这就是当你感到意外时的反应，因为我们知道这个行业里有很多人，在华盛顿、在很多其他行业也是如此，不管怎样，你永远看不到他们真实的一面。
What about how great she is? And she's so, she's so delightful and so smart and so gorgeous and so talented and so real and normal. Yeah. I know I said that about every guest of ours, but like I can't stop. That's the thing when you're surprised to me, because we know there's a lot of people in this business and in Washington, a lot of other businesses, whatever, that you never get like the real them.
而这才是真实的她。对啊。所以在那次晚宴上，我们聊起了那次剧组晚宴，杰，当时你说：“你们当时吃的是什么晚宴？”当你……你 literally 坐在……吉米。你 literally 坐在凯莉对面。这事最后总算绕回我身上了。
And that's the real her. Yeah. And so at that dinner, we talked about that cast dinner, Jay, when you're like, what dinner did you have? When you were, you literally sat across. Jimmy. You literally sat across from Karen. I came back to me eventually.
我们在吉米家。但是我们在……我们在金梅尔家，当时我根本不认识她，但她在制作我们大家都参与过的那档节目。我当时也有同样的反应。我就想：天哪，她太酷了，对自己以及自己的状态感到由衷的自在，而且超级真实。你会有一种直觉，觉得你面对的就是一个真诚的人。而且她真的很讨人喜欢。我们笑得前仰后合。
We were Jimmy's. But we were, so we're at Kimmel's and she, and I didn't know her at all, but she was producing that thing that we've all done. And I had the same, I had the same reaction. I was like, man, she is so cool and comfortable with who she is and her own skin and so real. And you're getting, you just had the sense that you were getting this genuine person. And she was a delight. We laughed a ton.
她太棒了。对啊。除了她撒谎说自己没听过我们的播客之外。她是个彻头彻尾的骗子。她自己都承认了。对啊。她是个大骗子。也许她应该来客串一个故事线。
She was great. Yeah. Except for she lied about watching them listen to the podcast. She's a dirty liar. She admitted it. Yeah. She's a dirty liar. Maybe she should do an arc.
她其实也……她也真的很有趣。比如她应该多演点喜剧。她确实很搞笑。为什么每次我们在这一行里遇到一个既nice又正常的人时，我们都会这么惊讶？对啊。因为我们见过了太多不正常的人。
She's also like. She's also really funny. Like she should do more comedy. She is. She's so funny. Why are we so surprised every time we meet somebody nice and normal in this business? Yeah. Because we know too many of the others.
但也许……也许这只是这个行业过去的一种遗留问题，现在我们应该坦然接受这样一个事实：其实这个行业里还是有很多非常nice、非常正常的人的。对啊。我不知道这到底是不是一种普遍现象。我不一定是指这个行业。我只是指生活。
But maybe, maybe that's just a vestige of what this business was and now we ought to just embrace the fact that there are actually a lot of really nice, normal people in this business now. Yeah. I don't know if it's a, it's a thing. It's not necessarily. I never mean the business. I just mean the life.
本质上。但也许……也许确实如此。我们身边有很多糟糕的人，也许这只是某种副产品。副产品。再见。我甚至都没料到它会发生。我甚至一点都没察觉。副产品。
Salt of it. But it's maybe, maybe it is. We get, there are bad people because maybe it's just a bye product. Bye product. Bye. I didn't even see it coming. I didn't even see it coming. Bye product.
其中精髓。但也许，也许确实如此。我们发现，有坏人是因为也许这只是个副产品。副产品。再见。我甚至没有预料到。我甚至没有预料到。副产品。
Bye product. Bye product. Bye product. Smart, lost, smart, lost, smart, lost. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjarf. Smart, lost. Smart, lost.
再见，产品。再见，产品。再见，产品。Smart，lost，smart，lost，smart，lost。SmartList 是由贝内特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·安杰夫 100% 有机手工制作的。Smart，lost。Smart，lost。
Smart, lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smart，lost。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。